there are over 550 million firearms and
worldwide circulation that's one firearm
for every 12 people on the planet the
only question is how do we learn the
other 11
step number one open up a bank or
manufacture war materials like weapons
raw materials soldiers or services step
number two don't just pray for war lobby
for war push your politician friends for
more conflicts step number three support
both sides of the war so that you come
out on top no matter who wins step
number four sit back relax and bask in
all that sweet cash flow as innocent men
women and children perish
[Music]
war is a racket it always has been
it's possibly the oldest easily the most
profitable as surely the most vicious is
the only one international in scope it
is the only one in which the profits are
reckoned in dollars and losses in lives
there's something special about war for
people who live in first world countries
it may seem like a far-off concept that
would never happen here and yet over the
past three thousand four hundred years
of human history we've spent only 268 of
love in peace but the business of war
goes much further back than that but the
first one ever recorded back in 2700 BCE
and Mesopotamia
this makes the industry of war half a
longer track record than the information
industry education and banking combined
along with many others war is the
ultimate discipline of any government
war is the government was life and death
is to humans if nations can meet the
challenge of war though survive if they
can't no perish war can also be looked
at as a racket but unlike your small
time mafia gangster asking for his
protection money or is big do you even
know what Vig means it's the US Air
Force dropping a bomb on your roof in
fact this racket is so so profitable
that at least 21,000 new millionaires
and billionaires were made in just the
US alone during World War one and that's
in early nineteen hundred's money and
it's because of these life or death
scenarios and these opportunities for
massive profits that incentivizes
governments to willingly forget about
its laws to forget about the prosperity
of its citizens the prosperity of its
economy to make sure that above all else
its military is well-funded
well-equipped and well-trained
that means if you can help governments
in their primal act of survival to
remain empowered by offering raw
materials weapons soldiers services to
soldiers you're gonna be the
government's best friend and they'll be
more than happy to not only pay for your
products with money that they have
but they'll borrow more money and even
create it out of thin air via their
central banks to make sure that they
live and because a government's first
concern is survival they're not all that
concerned about getting the best deal
that means you can easily overcharge for
your products it was all a scam
Halliburton was charging $45 for seats
pack Canada like Coke or Pepsi
Halliburton charge government $100 for
every bad clothes they washed and they
will gladly pay the markups to make sure
that your business and your salary are
taken care of how taken care of you may
ask normal business profit margins are
around 10% give or take but wartime
profits oh especially with the big wars
we're talking twenty percent 60 percent
a hundred percent three hundred percent
eight hundred percent the sky is the
limit
take DuPont for example during World War
one during the wartime years their
profits increased by over nine hundred
fifty percent or take the central
leather company at the same time during
that three years before the war profits
were around 3.5 million dollars not too
bad in 1916 alone 15 million a very
small increase of I don't know thirteen
hundred percent or take even less war
oriented companies like the American
Sugar Refining Company they averaged 2
million a year before the war and in
1916 6 million now you may be thinking
to yourself but Jake that was the great
war certainly war profits can't be that
insane today without another world war
can it and yeah you're right
but they're still pretty damn juicy
during the Iraq war often called the
most privatized war in history
KBR one of the main logistics supplier
contractors for the US we're talking
like food facilities etc got a whopping
thirty nine point five billion dollars
in Iraq related contracts with goe
logistics and the Kuwait Petroleum Corp
falling behind
with a measly thirteen point five
billion dollars in contracts now those
numbers are huge but what does that mean
for you if you were running one of these
companies
well KB R's parent company Halliburton
CEO was paid a nice forty two point six
million dollars in 2004
what about Tainan and kakhi the two
companies that provide the u.s. with
interrogators that were part of the
infamous Abu Ghraib prisoner torture
case khaki CEO made a fairly decent
twenty two point two million dollars in
2004 and Titan he takes the crown with a
forty seven point two million dollar
income in both 2004 and five revenue in
the tens of billions salaries and the
tens of millions I don't know about you
guys but I am 100% willing to help bump
some innocent villages for that kind of
money
I'm definitely getting the monetize for
listen but at the end of the day it's
not really the government that's paying
you all these juicy profits no no no
it's the citizens it's the plebs like
you and I that foot the bill the company
is overcharging taxpayers their taxes
and through this thing called inflation
where the government doesn't want to
anger us too much by raising taxes too
high to pay for all this stuff so they
just print more money that way they get
the stuff like they want by taxing us in
a sneakier fashion so at this point
you've completed step one you have a
copying that can provide warm materials
to the government so what's next in our
journey to becoming a war profiteer
during World War two automakers were
known as the arsenal of democracy
because they were able to transform
their production lines to make airplanes
tanks and trucks a very patriotic act
not so patriotic was when US troops
invaded Europe to find out the enemy
were also driving vehicles made by Ford
an Opel whose parent company was GM the
Washington Post reported that GM was an
integral part of the German war effort
the Nazis kind of invaded Poland without
the Swiss banks they cannot have done it
without GM Ford and GM definitely
weren't alone though chase-manhattan
were especially sinister with a
representative in Paris helping the
Nazis seize the assets of at least a
hundred Jews people that the Nazis
thought were really worth pursuing other
banks committed similar acts as well or
take the Gulf War for example where it
was found that businesses and
governments and at least 26 different
countries sold weapons to both sides
during the iran-iraq war or even more
recently Halliburton had a subsidiary in
the Cayman Islands that was selling
around 40 million dollars a year in
oilfield services to the Iranian
government what do all of these
companies have in common they have no
loyalty to their home country but it's
not just these particular companies if
you look throughout history funding and
supplying the enemy is all in a day's
work as a war profiteer
it's nothing personal see in the war
industry your customers are all the
governments of the world those are the
people that you're loyal to not just one
of them in your customer pool because if
you limit yourself to just your home
country not only are you basing all of
your revenue off of just that one nation
but you're leaving so much money on the
table so what if you're an American
company and your bullets end up being
use on US soldiers relax they're
replaceable the military has recruitment
unlock down my point
you shoot you know what isn't
replaceable though this opportunity to
make a literal and figurative killing so
no allegiance no patriotism if innocent
lives are lost oh well it's not like you
pull the trigger right
all right moving on to step number three
all right now for the tricky part you
can't make those juicy wartime profits
if there isn't a war now there's usually
a conflict somewhere around the globe at
any given time that you can profit from
but those profits are nothing compared
to the kind of money you can make one
big superpowers like the u.s. go to war
but here's where we run into a problem
the general public usually never wants
to go to war because they'll be the ones
fighting it so you got to do something
about that or else our whole scheme
falls apart if you've made it this far
you probably have a good amount of
government contacts may be some
political friends and powerful positions
heck maybe you even roast up in the
military so you have a ton of military
friends too so now is the time to lobby
for push for more conflicts max out your
campaign contributions get your friends
in the media involved they might fight
dirty using weapons of mass destruction
there are ties between Saddam Hussein
and al-qaeda anthrax smallpox dirty bomb
dirty bomb Rock al Qaeda connection both
of them want to see Americans get war
now seems all but inevitable short of a
bullet to the back of his head read he
leaves the country war is inexorable war
is inevitable and it is approaching
inexorably is war with Iraq inevitable
right now I think it's 95% inevitable on
you at this point right now tonight
don't see any other option but war to
you I'm asking you investment I don't
think there's a viable option for the
administration at this point we're way
too far out front in this sentence over
there guys let's get on with it let's
get it over with because it may seem
like you're spending a lot of money
right now but if you're successful it
will bring back billions more and again
you gotta stop worrying you're not gonna
be the one fighting this war yourself no
you're just gonna sell the shovels and
rake in those hefty profits so just stay
calm and let's move on to step number
four
[Music]
in the world of single-family real
estate investing the gold standard of
loans as the 30-year fixed-rate mortgage
right here in the US that is usually the
only type of loans long-term investors
go for because of how great and stable
it is in the world of war profiteering
you can think of contracts with the US
government as the equivalent to those
juicy 30-year fixed-rate loans it's the
gold standard and if you're really
well-connected and the war is really
dire then maybe you can even get these
special contracts called costs plus
percentage of cost this is basically
where the government promises to cover
all your expenses for the contract but
that's pretty common and it's not the
cool part the cool part is that after
they cover your expenses they'll pay you
a percentage of your expenses as profit
to you normally in the neighborhood of 2
to 7 percent a cost-plus arrangement the
critics say leaves a little incentive to
save the more taxpayer dollars
Halliburton spends the more Halliburton
makes cost-plus encourages you to run up
the cost of a program because you were
gonna get a percentage of the the end
result and so there's no incentive to
stay at Motel 6 standard ritz-carlton in
Qatar folks think about that for a
second if a project took to you I don't
know let's say a billion dollars to do
efficiently and your contract promised
you five percent you would only make a
measly 50 million dollars I mean that's
not even enough for a private jet come
on we can do better but let's say you
overpay for supplies here overcharged
layer and drive up the cost to let's say
I don't know four billion dollars boom
you just upped your profit for the same
contract doing work more inefficiently
to two hundred million dollars which
brings us a step number five
[Music]
let's say you've got a company you've
want some goats enter contracts with the
US government and the revenue starts
pouring in now what well you've already
got Uncle Sam in your door paying your
bills and since you're a savvy
businessman and you know without crying
new customers versus reselling to
current ones cost anywhere from 5 to 25
times more money why not just do
whatever it takes to keep daddy happy
because if daddy is happy you'll
probably get more contracts this means
that it is your duty to make sure that
all costs these contracts get fulfilled
even if you don't have the manpower or
infrastructure to support it it doesn't
have to be fulfilled well it just has to
be fulfilled fuel tankers need to get
the deliver to a military outpost but
you need to cross an active war zone
send the civilian contractors and
without telling them if they happen to
get attacked and a few of them are
killed
oh well replace them with some fresh
meat work your political and PR magic
and business will continue as usual it's
about contracts I believe fulfilling the
contract and replacing us if we died the
government needs translators and
linguists to relay mission-critical
Intel to soldiers if they can speak
broken English and are at least
illiterate they're hired you're gonna
get paid either way the toughest people
who may be spoke the language but it was
broken but couldn't that read it or
write it and I'm talking about English
and they were hired they will never give
it a test no one was given a test I was
never given at this have a contract to
provide clean water to the troops of
course provide water but forget about
the clean part we don't want to work too
hard right
one of Albertans employees saw something
wiggling in the water in his toilet bowl
so I went and tested the water in our
water storage tanks there was no
chlorine in them none the water we
showered in every single day was
extremely contaminated and when I talk
about contaminated water I'm saying
malaria typhus Giardia Cryptosporidium I
mean the list is really really long and
it gets even better if you're on a
cost-plus contract well you get paid for
how much you spend
why stay at a plebeian motel 6 when you
and your executives can stay at a luxury
resort when that truck you ordered
doesn't have an oil filter run it till
the engine blows Berna
by new one they got the wrong equipment
ordered the wrong stuff Computers
stealing boxes
new vehicles they push them out what
they called burn pits and they just set
it on fire claim it as a loss get more
money for the right equipment or the
right stuff they need it oh you don't
have an extra spare tire for that flat
you know with you blow it up
[Music]
congratulations because in just five
simple steps you successfully risen to
the elite club of war profiteers now
it's time to sit back and watch your
profits are up okay okay this is getting
a little ridiculous are all war
profiteers this unethical I would hope
not are there cases where government
contracts were actually really helpful
to the US government and the military
probably I really hope so but probably
like you before I started researching
the stuff I didn't really know that it
went on so the purpose of this video is
just to show you a glimpse of what can
happen if you choose to become a war
profiteer and like the video on the
business of banking I did we've barely
scratched the surface of the business of
war and I say this a lot but if you want
to see more videos on this topic please
let me know in the comments below and
I'll definitely make more because if
you're new to this channel I do read
every single comment and try to reply to
all of them as well
so just let me know
[Music]
[Music]